salam aliekum wa rahamtullah but i care
- were here near the infamous red-light
district and amsterdam and we're doing
an experiment if you like getting
people's opinion on the legalization of
prostitution and what we will try and do
is we try and gauge public opinion from
our perspective obviously as Muslims
right I mean we completely are against
such legalization we're going to put a
case forward to individuals today and
ask them questions integrative questions
thought-provoking questions but one
thing should be registered and noted in
the beginning of this is that the
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu wasallam
actually made a prediction and the
prediction that he made was that there
will come a time where people have
intercourse with one another like
donkeys in front of people in the public
and he said in another hadith that as a
result of that there will be a spread of
diseases the like of which had not
preceded the previous people so these
were two prophetic predictions of the
Prophet which we are seeing happen take
place and what more emblematic a place
for it to take place in this place here
and I'm stance we're gonna be asking
people about their views on a
legalization prostitution we'll see what
happens alright so we're we're just kind
of trying to do some research
obviously we're near the infamous
red-light district and we're asking
questions about what people think of
with the legalization of prostitution so
what's your opinion from this region I'm
from the UK what do I think
prostitution I don't I don't believe in
legalizing prostitution because I think
prostitution is wrong I think it's bad
for society
did your grades women so no no no one no
one I'm a good Catholic girl so no again
well I would have a lot to agree with
you on then on that point yes I thought
I thought we were yeah it's true it's
true fantastic no I agree with you no
it's very true and as we were kind of
doing research on this matter we found
that actually this is a very
commodifying and objectifying kind of
reality that women are actually putting
themselves women and women are screaming
to be
respected and treated with dignity so
where does the take the discussion about
women and freedom and rights for women
absolutely yes you ask more and more
women not men about where they stand on
that absolutely thank you very much for
your time
excellent all right
so how you guys doing first of all we
have a pretty good excellent as well
he's doing the best because he's an
excellent you guys said pretty good done
excellent know every exit in there
all right what are your names I'm Jamie
Kern I'm Maxie I'm Olivia I'm from the
UK originated thank you you too London
yep so I wanted to ask you a question
obviously this is quite controversial in
almost all the world now about the
legalization of prostitution so what are
your opinions on the legalization of
prostitution here in Holland since 2000
oh god I don't really know
well if it should be legal that kind as
well how are you from the UK yeah yeah
you are doing a really good UK accent no
the controversy surrounds and you guys
can come on
it's whether it should be criminalized
here in the here in Holland there is a
discussion about okay as well yeah yeah
I don't think it should be criminalized
and here at least you know you can see
see the women in the doorway and you
know they're doing well then are walking
some sort of street corner but you have
you have you tried anything with those
women of you experimental yourself of
you know no but but but like are they
being exploited or not so so so so so
that's what I do worry a wonder about
ones remain I guess if okay no no I'm
French I'm French
yeah yeah and I think
wants to go to the prostitutes are going
so shouldn't be green eyes as well yeah
some of the issues concern most
personally to human trafficking so they
so some say that yeah it's definitely
mellitus
I mean it's already criminal but the
issue is that since it's been legalized
here in Holland human trafficking which
of which entails slavery like sexual
slavery so on has increased so that's
the main argument that they use for
against it one of the main arguments is
increased everywhere anywhere yeah so
one of the studies that have been done
in 2013 which is the effect of human
trafficking prostitution on human
trafficking which has been done by Eric
Meyer and others and LSE University of
you know in the UK and this is also
published in the world development
Journal that they say that actually
countries generally which which
legalized prostitution alongside the
legalization increase in human
trafficking as well
and those countries like Sweden Sweden
criminalized there and there's a
decrease in human trafficking in that in
that regard so having having those facts
in mind does that change your opinion a
little bit yeah it doesn't matter if it
was gonna up increase human trafficking
back home and definitely not it was kind
of a mindset of saying that it would
probably a forward ya know not make as
many people on the street or so so yeah
I did vaguely know about some of the
issues with them with the legalization
some of the arguments but III understand
that yeah it could increase
yeah human trafficking but where the
prohibition is the right way of doing it
or whether we need more education and
more safeguards for women who do decide
to do sex work if they are deciding to
do sex work so so I don't think it
should be criminalized because I think
you should be able to if you want to pay
for it if you want to sell it you should
be able to do that but yeah I do you
guys in a scenario which might be a bit
weird all right this might
I'm not sure if you're intending to use
the services here and your holidays but
what I was gonna say was that say for
instance because you know in this
country right you have to pay before the
services are done all right so you have
to actually pay the money before I
obviously they've got buttons in there
and stuff if they feel like they're
being reps so if you have to pay for the
services for instance right and you go
in I mean you're young glad wherever
maybe it's not gonna happen with you but
you take off your shirt and you start
getting ready and she says you know what
I'm not attracted to you
get out but she's already taken your
money right so can you see the issues
here I mean what would you do in that
scenario well can you get a refund you
can't get a refund you can't get
everything well
well I suppose fifty is it fifty euro
zone how much is it must happen on the
street when it's not well it's not like
like legislature and probably much worse
consequences happen they I guess it's
the same kind of argument with weed like
you know if you legalize it you can kind
of measure the thing and you know that
there is a physical substance being
people and we're different yeah I guess
you yeah I guess legislation is never
really gonna take people's feelings into
account
I mean I suppose I suppose even though
you are paying for it the woman doesn't
have to really accept it so and so I
understand that he pissed off my eight
yeah but this is 50 pound 15 euros
yeah you've wasted that money but you
can't exactly force yourself on a woman
because 50 euros okay how about how
about this I mean for one more story
another scenario so you say you've paid
the money she's happy to have you you go
inside this room you close the curtains
or whatever is and then afterwards you
start having intercourse you know three
minutes in you know she starts saying
get off me get off me right and then she
starts saying that you raped she pushes
the button she says you raped her
because you didn't get off her as
quickly as you should have
now you see how that can be quite a
challenging scenario
how would you avert that I don't know I
I've never been in that situation and I
never hope I would be but yeah cuz that
is really great you can't release sorry
I don't know I don't I don't know I'm
thinking here and and and yeah I mean I
don't want any woman to be raped and and
yeah issues with consent and things like
that but but yeah that's real your mind
thank you very much guys for for your
for your contributions take care guys
thank you take care yeah so as you guys
have seen the main argument seems to be
one of Liberty a woman should do
whatever she wants to do if you want to
sell the body you can sell the body if
you want to buy it you should be able to
buy it so it's one of freedom but the
main challenges we've seen also has been
one of restriction of freedom quite
ironically as well because yeah you're
increasing the freedom supposedly for
one group of consumers and suppliers in
the case of the prostitutes but you
would be restricting the freedom of
those people being human trafficked
because the demand is increasing and of
course because those people don't have h
have a choice in the matter whatsoever
so if something that you're doing the
byproduct of which is an increase in
slavery in society here in Europe the
question is should we continue doing
that thing or not but here when we go
back to the issue of human trafficking
though someone could argue though that
if if you give because what it is is
that's a different question it is it is
the rules and legislation which huge
which which shoots have a certain
control in it when that's failing then
you have the human trafficking and the
abuse and misuse of the women so control
it have put your focus as a government
or as a police state or whatever all of
that
not under women from your experience and
from your knowledge here in the country
you know like when for example when
women closed the curtains and they and
they offer the service or whatever they
are offering for X amount of minutes I
don't know how it works
yeah so when that happens um the concern
here is that what happens in the closed
room as well so for example if a woman
is being raped there you have a button
immediately there will be a a a please
or whatever around so if that if they
press the button and then the person who
is the the one who is the alleged so the
one who's being alleged of rape if
they're if they deny the allegation so
how do we resolve that kind of
initiative that is legislation because
it's a one on one situation right so and
another question I've always wondered as
well right so for example if someone
because you have to pay before you get
the service isn't it yes of course I
don't like you it would walk away and
say bye oh darling now yes so if the
payment is done before the service right
and the service is not provided so how
can that be resolved our bad sales woman
yeah so but doesn't that doesn't that
mean that there's a miscarriage of
justice in a sense because obviously if
the payment is not provided so for
example if you go inside and you pay the
money right not yourself some ex person
Tom goes in and pays the person right
and he pays the and then the woman says
you know what she looks at the person t
takes off his shirt you know it doesn't
look so good he doesn't want to continue
with this she says get out of the room
because Oh what what now what now it is
it is you have to make two rules very
clear how would you how would you uphold
those rules I mean I'm just really
wondering if you have to make that very
clear but that's a business contract for
that very moment and then that's not
being followed then there's a wrong
thing happening and then you have to
press charges or whatever sue somebody
trying I was think that would be quite
difficult to prove oh thanks
much fuel for your for your opinion what
they found was that in 2013 well did
this this study which is was entitled
does does the leak the legalization of
prostitution increase human trafficking
I think that was the name of the study
right and it was in World Development
Journal right they found that when you
criminalize prostitution what that does
is it decreases human trafficking when
you legalize it increases and they
looked at more than one case study and
it was it was pretty
multi-disciplinarian and it's in the
sense that it was more than one
professor looking at it and so on so
just on that fact alone do you think if
that can be proven I mean human
trafficking is all always it's wrong yes
so we should stop that if it could one
way or another and I'm not clear what
it's it's it's I don't know the solution
I see what you're saying and because
what human trafficking is is really as a
slavery isn't it so something has been
there prostitution is always something
that is there yeah even if it's very
like in China well I walked out with
Chinese people it's not allowed in China
but it's a lot in China if I go there
I'm very happy to get your opinion
because you seem to be quite balanced at
least in thinking that you know if
there's good enough evidence then then
it should be yeah thank you very much
for that sir okay thank you take care
all right so we've been able to gauge
some public opinion and there are mixed
as you would have expected mixed
opinions here in in Amsterdam about the
legalization of prostitution obviously
for an Islamic perspective prostitution
is one of the worst things you can do
because it's objectifying
commodifying women and it's putting them
in a situation of you know desperation
sometimes abuse they're very vulnerable
and obviously we believe in the five
objectives in the Sharia one of them
being the protection of AB or the
dignity of a human being and so we feel
like sexual intercourse should only be
done in the confines of
you know ones private spaces but also in
the institution through the institution
for example of marriage and so from our
perspective the case is quite clear I
mean just imagine this I mean this is a
place where you would see someone in the
back here literally prancing around you
know showing their bodies for display
almost kind of similar to what you see
in a butcher shop I mean you know slabs
of me moving around I mean you got to
think about a psychological state of a
person who would be literally standing
here with with red lights and so on
published publicizing their bodies in
order to make money really and that's
how many times does one have to do that
a day before it becomes taxing on the
body taxing on the mind how many
possibilities are there of abuse in that
process how much things can go wrong how
much aids can be spread how much STDs
can be spread and this of course goes
back to the prophetic tradition of
Prophet Muhammad's and a lot of Salaam
our prophet who predicted in the future
that there will come a time where people
will be having sex sexual intercourse
like dunk like donkeys in public and
then people will be doing it and not
having anything to say about it and this
society has acquiesced to a more to a
high extent to this to this practice of
prostitution to this practice of
prostitution happening in this country
despite the fact as we've mentioned that
human trafficking has gone up forced
labor has gone up sexual slavery has
gone up and so on and so forth so I
think I would leave everyone here today
we're thinking about our purpose in life
how do you become self actualized a
human being is it by you know selling
your body I mean something so price that
should be aught to be potentially quite
private to you your your your physical
body giving that to as many men or women
and unfortunately in the case of
Amsterdam its men giving it to women for
the most part which is of course a slap
in the face to feminism which talks
about equality as well but all of that
being said what should we do I think we
should go back to basics as human beings
and think about what the purpose of life
is and I think that the purpose of life
is
when you are in line with the divine
will in line with your what you're going
to do is even being in this world and I
don't think it's this now before anyone
judges I mean we didn't come here in a
peak hour of peak time and we were
directed by the locals of course to come
to areas where there would not be any
commodification public publicizing of
bodies going on so with the hamdulillah
I wouldn't see anything we ought we
oughtn't not to have seen but it was an
experience which showed me unfortunately
the backward elements of European
society and civilization which ought to
be remedied by introspection frankly and
intellection two things which are part
of the European project and hopefully
can continue to be so salam aliekum wa
rahamtullah what i guess